what's good guys axl beats here for
anime uproar and luffy's newest form
gear fifth as well as all of the crazy
new information about his devil fruit
have definitely shaken up our
understanding of what our bouncy boy is
capable of so today we're going to be
taking a look back at his fruit and
everything that it's been able to do so
far in the story we're going to talk
about every form a couple of attacks
from each how and why luffy would make
use of these forms and if any of the new
information that we've recently received
changes our perspective or understanding
on any of these things
so there's about 25 years of rubbery
innovation to take a look at so let's
get into it before we do though if
you're enjoying the one piece content on
this channel be sure to leave a like and
a comment with a suggestion on a video
you might want to see in the future
speaking of the future you should
definitely subscribe to the channel and
hit that bell because we have a ton of
great content in the works ringing that
bell is the best way to stay notified
for our uploads and it's a totally free
way to support the channel but with all
of the youtube stuff out of the way
let's talk about luffy spoilers and all
if you've been keeping up with the manga
you know that the gomu gomunomi is not
what we expected it isn't simply a
paramecia fruit that turns the user's
body into rubber but it's in fact a
mythical zone fruit that the world
government has been searching for for
800 years
it is actually the human human fruit
model nika
nika of course being the sun god that
brings smiles to the world and fought
for freedom for all we've seen a few
other human human fruits in the past and
in both cases they have been fairly
unique for example chopper's human human
fruit is the only fruit in the series
that we know of that has no effect on a
normal human being but it also can be
augmented by the rumble ball to not just
have three forms like other typical
zones
but seven
something which luffy was very
interested in originally and ironically
has become something that he's met
himself as luffy has shown seven major
forms his base form gear second gear
third gear fourth bound man gear fourth
tank man gear fourth snake man and the
new gear fifth interestingly enough the
other human human fruit that we've seen
the series is another mythical variant
this being sengoku's buddha model which
in itself is a pretty unique parallel to
nika each of these being
pseudo-religious leaders and while the
buddha might not be a god himself he is
someone who is reincarnated as the dalai
lama
similar to how nika joyboy and luffy are
connected so while people might think
the situation with luffy is a little bit
strange there's at least some sort of
precedent for it specifically with human
human devil fruits the hitohito no me
model nika is described by the gorosei
to give its user a rubbery body and to
bring smiles to the world around them by
becoming the embodiment of the warrior
of liberation the sun god nika however
once the fruit awakens it drastically
evolves in its base form as i mentioned
luffy was given a rubbery body and lost
his ability to swim common to all devil
fruits a rubber body allows him to
stretch his arms legs neck or really any
part of his body ladies and
slingshotting bouncing or rebounding
them at enhanced speeds
but it also offers other properties
associated with rubber it makes him
immune to electricity physical attacks
like bullets or punches will bounce off
of him unless they are infused with haki
and he can even be inflated like a
balloon and while it took him some time
through stretching or contorting his own
body he learned to be able to unleash
some pretty devastating attacks
however there is a theme with the fruit
in general and it seems to be more about
ingenuity than just springyboy
goldboeing
luffy's most iconic attack in his normal
form is the human
human
pistol
uh this seems like a good time to say
that i'm not calling it that we're gonna
stick with the normal names that we've
known for two and a half decades because
something about human human just sounds
weirdly gross to me for some reason so
on that note let's talk about some gum
gum attacks
most of which are named after guns or
artillery
i would talk about all of them but the
wiki lists
90 of them
for just
first gear
and we'd be here for literal hours
so instead since this video is already
going to be pretty long
i'm just gonna cover a couple of the
major ones a few of the goofy ones are
just ones that i think are very fun so
as i was saying the gum gum pistol is
probably luffy's most iconic attack he
pulls his arm back and slings it forward
to crash into his opponent with some
pretty strong force but if he really
needs to send someone flying he will use
both arms as opposed to just one in
essentially the same motion crashing
into his opponents after slinging them
back with gum gum bazooka if luffy needs
some mobility he has access to gum gum
rocket where he can extend his arms grab
hold of something and use it to
slingshot himself at high speeds
gum gum gatling is more like a barrage
of punches with luffy moving his fist so
fast that it looks like he has multiple
fists flying at his opponent this can be
a finisher for when luffy really wants
to beat someone down or doesn't want to
send them flying or just needs to deal
with a big group of enemies gun gum
rifle is kind of an upgraded pistol
while he stretches his arm back he
starts coiling it and twisting it around
and as he releases it the extra force
from the torsion crashes into the
opponent for a much more focused and
damaging hit and the last of the major
attacks that come up fairly often is gum
gum whip this is a as you might imagine
whip-like attack where luffy uses one of
his legs to hit a big group and kind of
just cleave through them luffy also has
a defensive ability that comes up pretty
often in gum gum balloon by inflating
himself with air luffy's able to kind of
bounce things off of himself or keep
himself fairly protected now for a
couple of my personal favorites gum gum
fireworks has luffy jumping up in the
air twisting himself up and then
unwinding as he springs his arms and
legs out to chaotically attack a big
group gumgum ufo turns his legs into a
propeller that allows him to float
around in the air and lastly water luffy
which is just luffy after he drank a
bunch of water as you can see there's a
lot of straightforward uses for the
rubbery properties that the fruit gives
but at the same time there's also some
ingenuity that luffy puts into these
abilities some imagination would have
had to go into some of these or he would
have never gotten as far as he has of
course things don't just stop there
though as he wasn't just limited to what
he could think of himself one of luffy's
biggest strengths has always been his
ability to adapt and learn from his
opponents
the first big example of this is
obviously gear second which could be
considered the second zone form inspired
by cp9 surokushiki more specifically
shave luffy gets the idea of upping the
speed of his movements and attacks by
pumping the blood throughout his body
faster than normal luffy turns red and
begins to let out steam amplifying his
speed and strength while originally he
could only enter this form by using his
legs to act as pumps he later learns to
activate it in more simple and efficient
ways gear second originally drained him
so much that it could be a threat to his
lifespan however with practice and after
his two years of training this seems to
all be but a non-issue now when active
luffy is able to overcome cp9's iron
body skills and at least injure any
non-logia opponent that he fought in the
first half of the grand line even people
like blackbeard or magellan which makes
this a pretty big jump in comparison to
his base form which was more or less
useless even against cp9 the names of
luffy's attacks in this form tend to
have jet in them to demonstrate the
boost in speed for example gum gum
pistol becomes gum gum jet pistol and
rather than a big start up from his
normal form luffy can basically throw a
normal punch except it moves so fast
that it becomes nearly invisible with
only the impact really being seen
when he first uses it against bluno
bluno makes a joke about having warning
that the attack is coming luno then uses
shave and despite moving incredibly fast
himself luffy is still able to land a
punch that bluno can't even react to
post time skip though we see a bit of
theme changing with luffy's attack names
especially in gear second while jet
attacks still show up we also add in the
hawk series basically these are jet
attacks with the addition of haki for
example gumgum redhawk which actually
sees luffy's attacks moving so fast that
the friction against the air ignites the
punch and it becomes a fiery dedication
to his brother ace we also see attacks
being named after other birds like
eagles or rocks but they're all
essentially just hockey powered jet
attacks while these attack names might
still be referencing to weapons like the
desert eagle this could have also been a
reference to luffy's fruit being a zone
type this whole time on the gear third
the level up which was definitely the
most incomplete when it was first used
luffy blows into his thumb and sends air
into his bones inflating them to
gigantic proportions while this is
typically used to make his arms bigger
it can later be passed down to any part
of him and i do mean any ladies okay
i'll stop while he would originally
inflate his entire arm he can later send
the air to his feet or even just to his
hands by inflating individual parts of
himself rather than full limbs he can
lessen the air resistance his attacks
need to deal with so most of his more
quick gear third attacks will be
isolated like this well when he needs
bigger force the entire limb tends to be
inflated while insanely powerful this
originally came with a downside of
shrinking luffy to about half his size
for a period at first this lasted for a
considerable amount of time but as he
practices it it shortens pretty quickly
and post time skip it doesn't seem to
affect him at all something to mention
here is that you can't just blow into
your thumb to inflate your body and
while luffy has always been creative
this is the first thing that i might
really consider an imaginative power i.e
luffy thinking up something that would
be cool and bending reality to fit that
idea like yeah there's always been some
wacky stuff but it's more or less been
able to be made sense of when you
consider someone having luffy's body but
this is different air just can't do what
he's asking it to do
again this could be a reference to the
nika fruit which is only limited by the
user's imagination some of his attacks
early on would be given the giant name
scheme for example giant pistol giant
axe or giant whip which are all
functionally the same as their gum gum
counterparts just on a much larger scale
where we start to see variation from
those original forms is when haki is
implemented into these attacks here much
like the gear second hockey attacks we
get some animal naming for example
elephant gun and grizzly magnum
essentially the gear 3 versions of
pistol and bazooka a personal favorite
of mine in this form is thor elephant
gun which adds in an electrical element
to the attack itself again something to
note is that this inclusion of fire and
lightning that we've been seeing in
luffy's attacks is pretty strange while
fire can be believable with the friction
explanation lightning just doesn't make
sense because rubber can't conduct
electricity so here would likely be yet
another example of luffy's imagination
being brought into reality luffy's
fourth fifth and sixth forms are all in
his fourth gear the first form bound man
luffy learned in ruskina but was first
seen in dressrosa rather than blowing
into his thumb luffy instead blows into
his arm and again inflates himself while
he doesn't become as big as in third
gear he definitely gets a lot more buff
than normal he's pretty top heavy though
in bound man and all four of his limbs
are covered in armament hockey batman is
unable to stop bouncing and it can't
stand in place however it can retract
its limbs into its body for some really
powerful abilities this form focuses
less on that slingshot effect that luffy
is famous for and more on compression
and release basically just like how
luffy used to pull his arm back and
launch them forward he now pulls his
arms inside of themselves and when
enough pressure is built up they launch
out
similarly he can do this with his legs
and if he does it in quick succession he
can kind of fly for a little bit some of
the major downsides of this form is that
the range is pretty significantly
limited on top of that he can't keep the
form up indefinitely and it wears them
out pretty badly originally luffy is
unable to move after using gear fourth
he also loses the ability to use haki
for about 10 minutes and when he has to
use it twice in a row after fighting
doflamingo he is unconscious for the
next three days as is tradition with
luffy's forms though the more he
practices with it the more these effects
start to fade away though at least up to
his fight with kaido he does still have
some limitations on his use of these
abilities
the bread and butter attack for bound
men is gomu gomu no king kong gun which
is the attack that ultimately defeats
doflamingo later this is evolved in wano
and he can actually project haki from
his fists so that he never has to make
direct contact and even so without
touching the object it's strong enough
to shatter a block of steel in terms of
involving imagination in this ability
all of gear fourth in general is pretty
beyond what rubber should be able to do
but what always stands out to me as
being especially strange is kong organ
or monkey king murder of crow's cannon
in english which just doesn't roll off
the tongue the same way this attack sees
luffy moving his arms from side to side
so fast that it looks like he has three
arms on each side and each of them uses
kong gun moving on to our fifth form
though we have tank man which is
something this was only really used
against cracker on whole cake island and
it has luffy taking on a much more
defensive gear forth that uses the
quickly burning metabolism that gear
fourth causes in order to keep eating
more and more of crackers biscuit
soldiers the form doesn't really offer
much outside of appetite and defense but
there is a pretty substantial jump in
both of those cracker was previously
able to stab into bound man but as tank
man his attacks are completely useless
so if bound man is power and tank man is
durability then snake man form number
six is all about speed while luffy's
legs and arms are a little bit bigger
the rest of him stays fairly normal in
size on top of that hockey doesn't seem
to spread across the entire limb like it
does with bound men and stops about
two-thirds of the way through because of
the lack of inflation in this form
though luffy is much more vulnerable to
damage in comparison to the other two
but that's not that big a problem when
you consider just how fast this form is
and that in an emergency luffy can
always switch between forms luffy's
attacks in snake man are much faster and
while they do deal less damage than
bound man might offer it's much more
concentrated which can make up for it
the true utility of this form is python
with this luffy can redirect his punches
in mid-air and allow them to build up
more and more speed and momentum as well
as adjust his attacks if they're dodged
basically turning his punches into
honing attacks that do more damage the
longer they're trying to hit the target
the snake man version of gum gum pistol
which takes python into account is
culverin or great serpent cannon and
it's kind of his go-to in this form
although we do see a couple upgraded
attacks as well all of these forms take
advantage of luffy's imaginations in
some way or another turning his basic
rubber abilities into things which are
almost incomparable when placed next to
each other it's like showing someone a
bike and they make you a car the
function of going from point a to point
b is the same but the ability the form
and the capacity are just not even in
the same league and that leads us to
luffy's newest form and his most
powerful one by far
gear five goro say explained that in
this awakened state the nika fruit's
powers are only limited by luffy's
imagination and he can effectively do
anything something which we see being
shown off as he moves and interacts with
the world kind of like a looney tune
character luffy in his sun god state
gets what looks like flaming hair but
aside from that his form seems to be
pretty similar to his basic form he also
seems to always be laughing and smiling
which is likely where the title of joy
boy comes in while we've only seen bits
of this form so far this form does seem
to easily hold up with and overcome
kaido by breaking the laws of the world
around them to fit luffy's imagination
turning the floor into rubber and
bending it up to deflect kaido's boro
breath luffy can enlarge his body and
coil it around kaido and he can even
swing kaido around so fast that it looks
like his eyes are popping out of his
head basically if a looney tune could do
it so can luffy just as with every new
form though this will likely come at a
pretty substantial cost and if i had to
guess it could be pretty close to fatal
gear 2 saw luffy shortening his lifespan
and becoming worn out with excessive use
gear 3 shrunk his body and after his
last attack on lucci left him unable to
move gear 4 leaves him unconscious
sometimes for several days
and if it keeps escalating gear 5 might
cause something much more significant
but we'll have to wait and see the idea
of luffy's fruit being a mythical zone
though makes every aspect of his
abilities feel totally different and in
some ways much more understandable the
focus on different forms something which
we haven't really seen other paramecia
do very often if at all mixed in with
this imaginative understanding of how
rubber could be possibly used definitely
helps us paint a picture of how luffy's
attacks came into being while some
people might feel like the model nika
fruit came out of nowhere i think it's
the final piece of the puzzle that we
needed to fully understand or get a
grasp on luffy's powers
but what do you guys think do you like
the model nika change or do you hate it
or maybe you just think we need more
time to really see how it shakes out as
for luffy's other forms which one's your
favorite for me i love gear 4 but
there's something always so cool about
second gear it's just so satisfying for
me that said though if gear 5 continues
to be as amazing as it was in the first
chapter there it might be a pretty easy
number one for me either way let me know
in the comments regardless let me know
what you guys think in the comments
if you enjoyed this video remember to
leave a like it really does help with
the youtube algorithm as well as helping
us to focus in on the content that you
want to see
and be sure to subscribe and ring the
bell so you don't miss any of the other
great videos coming your way you can
also follow us on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar or if you're looking for
more of me you can find me over on my
own channel axle beats thank you guys so
much for watching i hope you enjoyed and
until next time
remember to stay excellent